>>> ALL RIGHT.
HAPPY MIDWEEK,
FOOTBALL WEEK IN AMERICA.
THE
FOOTBALL NIGHT IN AMERICA FAMILY
ALL TOGETHER HERE.
MINUS CHRIS
SIMS WHO WE ONLY LET OUT ON
WEEKENDS.
RODNEY, TONY, MIKE
FLORIO, GOOD TO SEE Y'ALL.
NOT
GOOD TO GET THE NEWS WE WERE
GETTING DURING THE WEEK.
ADD TO
THE NFL, NO POSITIVE TESTS.
WEDNESDAY OBVIOUSLY THAT STORY
CHANGED IN NEW ENGLAND AND IN
TENNESSEE AGAIN.
AND WITH THE
RAIDERS.
SO THIS OBVIOUSLY IS
SOMETHING THAT'S GONNA CONTINUE
TO BE PART OF THE STORY.
AND
MIKE, I GUESS, TONY, LET'S START
THE CONVERSATION.
WHAT ARE WE
LOOKING AT HERE LONG-TERM IN THE
NFL IF WE GET TO THE REALITY
THAT TEAMS ARE GONNA MISS GAMES
AND NOT BE ABLE TO MAKE THEM UP?
>> I'LL START WITH TENNESSEE.
THEY'VE ALREADY HAD THEIR BYE
WEEK MOVED FROM WEEK 7 TO WEEK 4
TO ACCOMMODATE LAST WEEK'S GAME
BEING POSTPONED AGAINST THE
PITTSBURGH STEELERS.
NOW WITH
THE TITANS UNABLE TO GET BACK
INTO THEIR FACILITY ON WEDNESDAY
AS THEY PREPARE FOR THE BILLS TO
COME TO TOWN.
WE'RE ALREADY IN A
POSITION WHERE THE NFL HAS TO
TACK ON WEEK 18 TO THE SEASON.
MOVE THE PLAYOFFS BACK A WEEK.
SOMETHING THE NFL HAS
CONTEMPLATED BUT DIDN'T WANT TO
DO THIS EARLY IN THE YEAR.
BUT
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ALREADY
LOOKING AT BECAUSE THIS OUTBREAK
CONTINUES IN TENNESSEE.
NOW
WE'VE GOT A POTENTIAL OUTBREAK
IN NEW ENGLAND.
TWO OF THE 32
TEAMS SO FAR.
AND LOOK, AS THE
NUMBERS GO UP ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
AND AS GUYS CONTINUE TO
GO HOME EVERY SINGLE NIGHT,
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE THIS
EVER-PRESENT POSSIBILITY, NUMBER
1, OF INFECTION AT HOME.
AND
THEN NUMBER 2, OUTBREAK WHETHER
IT'S IN THE FACILITY, ON THE
SIDELINE, IN THE PLANE, ON THE
BUS OR ON THE FIELD DURING
GAMES.
>> I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
QUESTION ABOUT IT.
YOU'RE JUST
GONNA HAVE TO STAY FLEXIBLE.
AND
THERE ARE GONNA BE OUTBREAKS.
WE
ARE GONNA MISS PEOPLE IN CERTAIN
GAMES.
AND WE MAY HAVE TEAMS
THAT MISS GAMES.
I THINK THE NFL
HAS TO DEVISE SOME PLAN OF
ATTACK THAT WAY.
BUT IT'S NOT
GONNA BE FAIR.
IT'S NOT GONNA BE
EQUAL.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO DO
THE BEST WE CAN.
BECAUSE THIS IS
UNPRECEDENTED CIRCUMSTANCE.
>> AND I ALSO THINK THE PLAYERS
ARE GONNA HAVE TO BE COMPLETELY
AND TOTALLY COMMITTED TO SLLTH
THEMSELVES.
WHETHER
FROM ISOLATING THEMSELVES, JUST
BEING AT HOME, ISOLATED.
MY WIFE
AND MY DAUGHTER CAUGHT THE VIRUS
BECAUSE MY DAUGHTER BROUGHT IT
TO HOME, AND SHE'S A NURSE.
AND
IT'S JUST, LIKE, YOU GIVE
SOMEBODY A SIMPLE HUG, AND ALL
OF A SUDDEN IT COULD PASS.
IT'S
JUST A SCARY THING.
AND YOU LOOK
AT THE COMPETITIVE IMBALANCE,
YOU LOOK AT WHAT THE PATRIOTS
HAD TO GO THROUGH WITHOUT CAM
NEWTON, WITHOUT STEPHON GILMORE.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE FANS BEING
UPSET.
A LOT OF COACHES, I'M
SURE, ARE UPSET LOSING THEIR
STAR PLAYERS.
>> NO DOUBT.
MIKE'S TALKED EVERY
WEEK TO NOTRE DAME FOOTBALL
PLAYERS AND THEIR OPPONENTS.
AND
THESE YOUNG MEN, THEY'RE DOING
EVERYTHING, MIKE.
WE TALKED TO
IAN BOOK AND SEAN CRAWFORD.
AND
THEY SAY HEY, WE GO, WE COME
HOME.
I DON'T GO OUTSIDE.
I
DON'T GO ANYWHERE.
I'M COMMITTED
TO THAT.
AND AS RODNEY SAYS,
THAT'S THE ATTITUDE YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE TO TAKE IF YOU WANT TO BE
AVAILABLE FOR 16 WEEKS.
>> AND A LOT OF THE GUYS ARE
DOING THAT.
IT'S A REALITY THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF PLAYERS IN
THE LEAGUE WHO.ING THROUGH ALL
OF TRAINING CAMP AND THE FIRST
THREE WEEKS OF THE YEAR.
AND
RODNEY, I THINK YOU GIVE US --
ONE, THANKS FOR SHARING THAT.
TWO, HOPE EVERYBODY IN YOUR
FAMILY IS OKAY AND CONTINUES TO
DO OKAY.
BUT BY SHARING THAT,
IT'S JUST A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF
YOU CAN DO EVERYTHING RIGHT, AND
YET THE PEOPLE WHO SOME
TANGENTIALLY IN CONTACT WITH YOU
MAY SPREAD IT.
I WAS LOOKING AT
THE TOUR ON THE WHITE HOUSE.
WE'RE NOT GONNA GET POLITICAL
HERE.
BUT JUST USE THIS AS
CONSTRUCTIVE.
IN THE DEBATE PREP
FOR THE PRESIDENT LAST WEEK,
WERE HOPE HICKS WHO TESTED
POSITIVE, KAYLEE MCANANEY, CHRIS
CHRISTIE ALL TESTED POSITIVE.
ALSO IN THAT ROOM, WHICH SOUNDS
LIKE IT WAS A RELATIVELY SMALL
AREA, WERE RUDY GIULIANI, JARED
KUSHNER, WHO HAVE NOT TESTED
POSITIVE.
THE VIKINGS AND THE
TITANS ON THE FOOTBALL FIELD.
WE'RE NINE DAYS REMOVED FROM
THAT.
THE QUARTERBACK WHO TESTED
POSITIVE HAD 48 SNAPS.
DIDN'T
PASS TO ANYBODY ON THE OFFENSIVE
LINE OR ANYBODY ON MINNESOTA.
SO
IT'S ALL ILLUSTRATIVE OF WE JUST
DON'T KNOW.
THERE IS NO ANSWER.
AND WE HAVE TO BE VERY CAREFUL.
THIS IS A BEHIND THE SCENES
CONVERSATION.
IS IT AN
INVESTIGATION?
OR IS THE NFL
TRYING TO DO RECONAND FIND OUT
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THESE
FACILITIES?
>> YOU HAVE TO BE VERY CAREFUL
WHEN YOU START BLAMING
INDIVIDUALS OR PEOPLE FROM BEING
GUILTY, QUOTE, "UNQUOTE, IN
THIS.
STARTING OF A SPROED.
SPREAD.
SOMETIMES IT JUST
HAPPENS BY ACCIDENTAL CONTACT
THAT YOU DIDN'T EVEN KNOW ABOUT.
>> MIKE, THAT'S A VERY GOOD
POINT.
AND I'VE TALKED TO
MULTIPLE COACHES WHO BELIEVE
THAT THE LEAGUE IS MORE INCLINED
TO PLACE BLAME THAN JUST SAY OH,
WELL, IT HAPPENED.
AND THE
LEAGUE'S ATTITUDE IS IF YOU
FOLLOW OUR PROTOCOL, EVERYTHING
WILL BE FINE.
WHICH MEANS IF
SOMETHING ISN'T FINE, YOU
MUSTN'T HAVE FOLLOWE
PROTOCOLS.
AND THERE'S SOME
TENSION BETWEEN THE TEAMS AND
THE LEAGUE.
BECAUSE THERE'S THIS
BELIEF THAT THE LEAGUE WANTS TO
BE ABLE TO SAY, IF ANYTHING GOES
SIDEWAYS, IT'S NOT OUR FAULT.
IT'S NOT OUR PROTOCOLS, IT'S
YOUR FAULT BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T
FOLLOW THEM PROPERLY.
>> YOU GUYS LIVED YOUR LIVES IN
LOCKER ROOMS.
HOW WOULD YOU FEEL
IF YOU'RE IN THIS SITUATION
WHERE YOU WERE KANSAS CITY, AND
YOUR TEAM, NEW ENGLAND AFTER
NEGATIVE TESTS, EVERYBODY WHO
TOOK THE FIELD AND JUST SENT OFF
A NEGATIVE TEST.
AND NOW YOU'RE
FINDING OUT THAT STEPHON GILMORE
HAS TESTED POSITIVE, AND WHO
KNOWS WHO ELSE COULD HAVE BEEN
POSSIBLY CARRYING THE VIRUS AT
THAT POINT WHEN YOU PLAYED THEM?
HOW DO YOU GET YOUR MIND ABOUT
BEING STRAIGHT ABOUT PLAYING
NEXT WEEK AND THE WEEK AFTER
THAT?
>> IT'S TOUGH, MIKE.
BECAUSE YOU
JUST DON'T KNOW.
YOU COULD DO
EVERYTHING -- AND I THOUGHT I
DID EVERYTHING PERFECTLY SINCE
MARCH.
ISOLATING, WEARING MY
MASK AT HOME.
THE ONLY PLACE I
WOULD GO WAS ON THE GOLF COURSE.
AND I WOULD BE THE ONLY PERSON
ON THE GOLF COURSE WITH A MASK
ON.
IT'S TOUGH.
AND A LOT OF
THESE YOUNG MEN, THEY ARE SO BIG
AND SO STRONG AND THEY FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE SO HEALTHY.
THEY FEEL
LIKE THEY'RE IMMUNE TO CATCHING
THIS VIRUS.
A LOT OF THEM, YOUNG
PEOPLE, THEY JUST DON'T TAKE IT
SERIOUS.
AND AFTER SEEING MY
WIFE AND SEEING MY DAUGHTER GO
THROUGH THIS SITUATION, IT'S
SCARY.
WHETHER YOU LOSE YOUR
SENSE OF TASTE, SMELL, YOU SLEEP
FOR EIGHT HOURS BUT YOU WAKE UP
AND FEEL LIKE YOU ONLY HAD 20
MINUTES OF SLEEPING.
THESE ARE
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT SYMPTOMS
THAT YOUR FAMILY MEMBERS, YOUR
LOVED ONES ARE FEELING, MAN.
IT'S SCARY.
SO YOU THINK I'M
GONNA TRUST A 22-YEAR-OLD GUY
THAT'S GONNA COME IN THE LOCKER
ROOM AND TRUST THAT HE'S GONNA
DO THE RIGHT THING?
AND HE'S GOT
MONEY IN HIS POCKET, HE'S USED
TO BEING OUT AND ABOUT AND
HAVING DIFFERENT PEOPLE COME
THROUGH.
IT WOULD BE VERY SCARY
FOR ME IN A LOCKER ROOM, COACH.
>> AND I TELL YOU, MY JUSTIN IS
GOING THROUGH IT.
HIS HIGH
SCHOOL IN TAMPA, THEIR FOOTBALL
TEAM HAS GOTTEN SHUT DOWN FOR
THE LAST TWO WEEKS.
A STUDENT
TESTED POSITIVE.
WELL, THEY'RE
TESTING EVERYBODY ELSE WHO'S
BEEN IN CONTACT WITH THAT
STUDENT.
SO FAR NONE OF THE
TEAMMATES, NONE OF HIS TEAMMATES
HAVE TESTED POSITIVE.
BUT THEY
CAN'T PLAY.
THEY'RE IN
ISOLATION.
>> THERE'S A WEEK 18 POSSIBLE, A
WEEK 19 PUSHING GAMES BACK.
JUST
THE START OF THE CONVERSATION.
THE OTHER REALITY IS WE MAIN
HAVE EVERYBODY PLAY 16 GAMES AND
GO BY WINNING PERCENTAGE.
THAT'S
WHY THE COMMISSIONER HAS SET UP
THIS ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO DEAL
WITH INEQUITIES THAT NORMALLY
WOULDN'T HAPPEN IN THE NFL.
TONY, I'LL START WITH YOU,
RODNEY, THEN MIKE, AND YOU CAN
JUMP IN.
IF WE DON'T PLAY 16.
SOMEBODY PLAYS 14, WE DO IT ON
WINNING PERCENTAGE, ARE YOU OKAY
WITH THAT?
>> I THINK WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO.
AND I THINK WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
BE OKAY WITH.
IT BECAUSE THE
ALTERNATIVE IS GONNA BE TOUGH.
DO YOU HAVE TEAMS PLAY
TUESDAY/SUNDAY?
THAT'S NOT FAIR.
DO YOU HAVE TEAMS PLAY WITHOUT A
THIRD OF THEIR STARTING ROSTER
THAT'S NOT FAIR.
SO WE'RE NOT
GONNA HAVE AN EQUAL, FAIR
SITUATION.
AND I THINK WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO GET USED TO THE
IDEA OF WINNING PERCENTAGE IS
GONNA BE THE DETERMINANT.
>>> I THINK MAYBE WHAT THEY
SHOULD START CONSIDERING,
SHORTEN THE SEASON, MAYBE BY
FOUR GAMES.
THE POSSIBILITY OF
JUST SAYING HEY, FOUR GAME WE'RE
NOT GONNA PLAY.
I JUST THINK THE
MORE FOOTBALL YOU PLAY, THE MORE
GUYS COME INTO THE FACILITY, THE
MORE THEY'RE AROUND EACH OTHER,
YOU MORE YOU DON'T FEEL
COMFORTABLE JUST TO DO WHAT YOU
WANT TO DO AND NOT REALLY FOLLOW
ALL THE PROTOCOLS AND JUST GET
TOO COMFORTABLE.
IF YOU TAKE
AWAY FOUR GAMES WHICH IS ROUGHLY
A MONTH, I THINK THAT COULD
POSSIBILITY HELP THEM OUT A
LITTLE BIT, FLORIO.
>> YEAH, I HAD TWO DIFFERENT
COACHES POINT OUT LATE LAST WEEK
WHEN THIS FIRST WAVE FLASHED.
AND WE HAD TITAN, THEN PATRIOTS,
AND THE SCARE WITH THE SAINTS
THAT ENDED UP JUST BEING A FALSE
POSITIVE.
PLAY 12 GAMES.
BUFF
THINGS BACK IF YOU NEED TO.
REGROUP.
USE THE BUBBLE IF YOU
NEED.
TO BUT LET'S JUST DO 12
GAMES, EVERYONE PLAY 12 GAMES.
THOSE OF US WHO FOLLOW IT
CLOSELY HAVE BEEN WRESTLING WITH
IT LONG ENOUGH TO ACCEPT THE
FACT THEY MAY HAVE TO GO BY
WINNING PERCENTAGE.
ONCE THE
AVERAGE FAN STARTS TO GET A LOAD
OF THIS, THEY'RE GONNA BE
EXTREMELY UPSET ABOUT THE IDEA
OF MISSING THE PLAYOFFS BECAUSE
THE TEAM THAT GOT IN DIDN'T HAVE
TO PLAY THAT ONE EXTRA GAME THAT
THEY MADE UP A LOSS, AND YOUR
TEAM GETS IN INSTEAD.
>> THESE COUPLE OF THINGS REAL
QUICK.
THEN WE'LL MOVE ON.
AND
AGAIN, WE'RE JUST SPECULATING
WHICH IS DANGEROUS AND NOT
PRUDENT AT TIMES IN OUR
BUSINESS.
MAYBE YOU MADE SURE
THAT YOU PLAY ALL YOUR DIVISION
GAMES.
AND YOUR DIVISION CHAMPS
GO.
AND THEN WINNING PERCENTAGE
DETERMINES THE WILDCARDS.
IF YOU
END UP BEING ABLE TO PLAY ALL
SIX DIVISION GAMES.
IT'S THE
PUREST WAY TO GET THOSE FOUR
TEAMS IN.
AND THE OTHER THREE
ARE DETERMINED BY WINNING
PERCENTAGE.
THE SECOND START IS
THE BUBBLE YOU TALKED ABOUT,
MIKE FLORIO.
I THINK LIKE WE'RE
WATCHING IN BASEBALL HAPPEN
RIGHT NOW.
THEY'RE REALLY GOING
TO HAVE TO CONSIDER A BUBBLE, IF
NOT A ONE OR TWO-SITE BUBBLE FOR
THE POSTSEASON.
BECAUSE IT'S
GONNA BE VERY DIFFICULT TO
POSTPONE POSTSEASON GAMES IF YOU
GET A POSITIVE TEST HERE OR
THERE.
WE'RE A WAYS AWAY FROM
THAT.
WE'RE GONNA LEARN A LOT
MORE ABOUT HOW THIS HAPPENS
BETWEEN NOW AND THEN.
BUT THESE
ARE THINGS TO TALK ABOUT.
RODNEY, THERE'S A CHANGE IN
HOUSTON.
THE FIRST COACHING
CHANGE OF THE YEAR.
ALWAYS
COGNIZANT OF THE REALITIES OF
WHAT A COACHING CHANGE MEANS.
IT'S FAMILIES, IT'S PEOPLE.
IT'S
A REAL BUSINESS.
BUT IT IS OUR
JOB TO TALK ABOUT THE FOOTBALL
PART OF IT.
BILL O'BRIEN WANTS
THE DIVISION IN HOUSTON.
THEY
DID NOT GET OFF TO A GOOD START
THIS YEAR.
HAD THE TOUGHEST
SCHEDULE OF ANYBODY IN THE NFL.
HE'S OUT AT 0 AND 4. WHAT DO YOU
SEE AS THAT NEXT CHAPTER IN
HOUSTON?
>> LET'S FIRST TALK ABOUT BILL
O'BRIEN.
AND I THINK THE THING
THAT STOOD OUT TO ME WHEN I
FIRST GOT WITH COACH, HE ALWAYS
TALKED ABOUT BEING A HEAD COACH.
AND THE RESPONSIBILITY OF A HEAD
COACH IS NOT JUST BEING ABLE TO
COACH YOUR FOOTBALL TEAM, BUT
IT'S DEALING WITH ALL THE OTHER
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT COME
ALONG.
WHETHER IT'S PICKING
HOTELS, WHICH AIRLINE YOU'RE
GONNA FLY, ALL THE DIFFERENT
DISTRACTIONS.
AND YOU PUT THAT
ON TOP OF BILL O'BRIEN TRYING TO
BE A GENERAL MANAGER, WHICH I
THINK HE MADE MAJOR MISTAKES.
WHO TAKES ON BRANDON COOK'S
CONTRACT?
WHAT TRADES FOR A
SECOND-RATE DAVID JOHNSON?
THOSE
TYPE OF THINGS.
AND YOU GET RID
OF DEANDRE HOPKINS.
HE'S THE
BEST WIDE RECEIVER IN THE
NATIONAL FOOTBALL LEAGUE.
HOUSTON HAS A GREAT FOUNDATION
WITH DESHAUN WATSON.
BUT TO ME,
THEY JUST GET TO A POINT WHERE
HE WASN'T CONTINUING TO DEVELOP.
HE WAS JUST DROPPING BACK, AND
THERE WAS REALLY NO RHYME OR
REASON, THE TYPE OF OFFENSE THEY
WERE RUNNING.
WHOEVER THEY BRING
IN AS THE NEW COACH, THEY NEED
TO BE ABLE TO WORK WITH DESHAUN
WATSON AND GET THAT OFFENSE
GOING.
THEY HAVE TOO MUCH TAL
OENT THAT OFFENSE FOR IT TO BE
SO STAGNANT.
>> I'M NOT A BIG FAN OF --
>> GO AHEAD, COACH.
>> I'M NOT A BIG FAN OF INSEASON
CHANGES.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT
SERVES YOU.
IT DOESN'T HELP YOUR
TEAM PLAY BETTER.
THE ONE THING
IT MAY LET YOU DO IS GET A
HEADSTART ON THIS PROCESS.
AND
IF THE POWERS THAT BE IN HOUSTON
ARE LOOKING AND GOING TO DO A
DILIGENT SEARCH THEN MAYBE
THAT'S A GOOD REASON FOR IT.
BUT
OTHER THAN THAT, I DON'T LIKE
THE IDEA OF CHANGING COACHES.
I
DON'T THINK IT HELPS YOUR TEAM
AT RAUL MIDSEASON.
>> I'M STILL CONFUSED BY THE
WHOLE THING.
THEY TRIED TO HIRE
NICK CASERIO TO BE THE COACH.
THEY BLEW UP IN THEIR FACE.
O'BRIEN SERVED AS THE GM IN
2019.
AND AFTER THEY WON THE
DIVISION, MADE FOR THE ROUND OF
EIGHT, LED THE CHIEFS 24-0 IN
THE DIVISIONAL ROUND BEFORE IT
ALL FELL APART AS WE ALL KNOW.
THEN THEY DECIDE TO MAKE HIM THE
GENERAL MANAGER THAT.
VALIDATED
EVERYTHING THAT HE DID.
THEY
RATIFIED EVERY DECISION HE MADE.
THEY MAKE HIM THE GM OFFICIALLY.
THEY GET THE SCHEDULE FROM HELL
OUT OF THE GATES.
THE STEELERS.
THEY LOSE TO THE VIKINGS.
THAT'S
THE ONLY GAME THEY LOST THEY
SHOULD HAVE WON.
AND NOW BILL
O'BRIEN'S PERFORMANCE AS THE GM
IN FOUR GAMES GETS THE MULTIYEAR
HEAD COACH FIRED.
IT'S NOT LIKE
OWNERSHIP WASN'T ON BOARD WITH
EVERYTHING THAT'S HAPPENED FOR
THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF.
NIALL
OF A SUDDEN THE GUY'S GOTTA GO.
IT REALLY CONFUSED ME WHY IT
HAPPENED.
>> IT'S AN INTERESTING JOB WITH
DESHAUN WATSON.
SOMEONE THINKS
HE HAS ALL THAT STAR QUALITY.
AND IT'LL BE VERY INTERESTING TO
WATCH HOW THE NAMES START TO
DEVELOP THERE.
HE'S AT A PLACE
WHERE A NAME HAS COME UP A LOT
BECAUSE OF HIS WORK WITH THE
KANSAS CITY OFFENSE.
FOR THE
FIRST TIME I READ THAT BILL
O'BRIEN WAS LET GO, THE FIRST
THING I THOUGHT OF WAS, WHAT IF
NEW YORK UPHELD THE TOUCHDOWN TO
WILL FULLER ON SUNDAY?
AND THEY
WIN IN OVERTIME.
THREE WHAT IFS.
BUT ARE YOU TELLING ME IF THEY
WIN THAT GAME, HE'S NOT GETTING
FIRED.
SO YOU'RE TELLING ME THAT
YOU'RE MAKING A DECISION ON YOUR
HEAD COACH AFTER LOSING TWO OR
THREE.
TO THREE OF THE FOUR BEST
TEAMS, NO DISRESPECT TO
TENNESSEE.
AND A CALL THAT WAS
THIS CLOSE AGAINST MINNESOTA.
THERE OBVIOUSLY WERE OTHER
REASONS.
BUT I THINK IF THEY WIN
THAT GAME, HE DOESN'T GET FIRED.
SOMETIMES THAT'S WHY I'M WITH
YOU, TONY.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND
THE INSEASON CHANGES WHEN IT'S
SOMETHING NOT EGREGIOUS.
>> ONE QUESTION.
DID YOU GUYS
SEE THE WAY THAT DEFENSE PLAYED?
THE DEFENSE HAS BEEN PLAYING ALL
YEAR?
>> YEAH.
>> THAT'S ANOTHER PART OF IT.
THEY'RE JUST NOT PLAYING HARD
AND PHYSICAL.
THEY'RE NOT
PLAYING TOUGH, MIKE.
>> AND THEY HAD A COORDINATOR
CHANGE.
NOW HE IS THE INTERIM
HEAD COACH.
RODNEY, STAR OF THIS
GAME THIS WEEK.
EAGLES AND THE
STEELERS, THE EAGLES SURPRISE
OFFENSIVELY ALL OF US, SINCE WE
ALL PICKED THE 49ers ON THE
SHOW.
AND WE HEARD YOU,
PHILADELPHIA.
WE HEARD YOU LOUD
AND CLEAR.
I DON'T THINK THAT
LAST PASS FELL INCOMPLETE BEFORE
TWITTER STARTED LIGHTING UP.
AND
HERE ARE THE STEELERS,
>> I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING
HOW THE EAGLES OFFENSIVE LINE
DEALS WITH TJ WATT, BUD DUPREE,
AND THE BLITZ AND ZONES AND ALL
THE DIFFERENT CALLS, AND ALL THE
THINGS THEY DO ON THE DEFENSIVE
SIDE OF THE BALL.
THEY PUT A LOT
OF PRESSURE, A LOT OF HOLES IN
THAT SECONDARY.
GUYS TAKE A LOT
OF CHANCES.
THEY'RE VERY
AGGRESSIVE.
IF CARSON WENTZ, AND
THAT'S HOWHO I'M LOOKING FOR WHO
I'M LOOKING FOR TOO.
WILL DOUG
PETERSON TO A BETTER JOB OF
GETTING THE BALL OUT OF HIS
HANDS QUICKLY?
AND ALSO WILL
THEY CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON THEIR
BEST PLAYER?
WHICH I THINK IS
MILES SANDERS OFFENSIVELY.
>> AND I HAVE TO GIVE THUMBS UP
AND A LOT OF CREDIT.
CARSON
WENTZ PLAYED LAST SUNDAY NIGHT.
PLAYED AGGRESSIVE, DIDN'T PLAY
RECKLESS.
BUT I DON'T THINK THIS
WEEK BEN ROETHLISBERGER WILL
THROW TWO BALLS RIGHT TO HIM.
>> HE THREW IT RIGHT TO HIM.
BUT
YEAH, BEN ROETHLISBERGER, BETTER
THAN NEAL O'DONNELL.
AND HERE'S
THE QUESTION ABOUT THE STEELERS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW GOOD THEY
REALLY ARE.
ALL THREE OF THOSE
GAMES COULD.ING EITHER WAY, UP
16 POINTS IN THE THIRD QUARTER.
AND BUD DUPREE, CAMERON HAYWARD
CATCHING THE BALL IN THE END
ZONE.
THAT BALLING HAVE GONE
EITHER WAY TOO.
IT'S NOT LIKE
THE STEELERS HAVE DOMINATED
LESSER OPPONENTS.
I'M JUST
CURIOUS TO SEE WHAT THEY'RE
GONNA DO NOW AGAINST AN EAGLES
TEAM THAT'S FEELING PRETTY GOOD
ABOUT THEMSELVES.
>> AND TO YOUR POINT, THE
BRONCOS ONE WIN OUT OF THAT
GROUP GAME AGAINST THE JETS ON
THURSDAY NIGHT.
THE JETS ARE
PROBABLY AS BAD AS ANY TEAM IN
THE LEAGUE RIGHT NOW.
INDIANAPOLIS AGAINST CLEVELAND.
TONY, YOU HAVE TALKED ABOUT AT
LENGTH THE LACK OF DEFENSE THIS
YEAR IN THE NATIONAL FOOTBALL
LEAGUE.
THE ONE PLACE WE'VE SEEN
IT FOR A MONTH IS INDIANAPOLIS.
WHAT IS IT ABOUT THE COLTS'
DEFENSE THAT BEARS WATCHING AS
ONE OF THE BETTER DEFENSIVE
UNITS IN THE LEAGUE?
>> WELL, I THEY PLAY TWO OR
THREE
COVERAGES, THEY PLAY HARD.
IT'S
NOTHING FANCY.
AND HE SAYS I'M
GONNA GET GOOD PLAYERS AND I'M
GONNA TURN THEM LOOSE AND LET
THEM BE ATHLETIC.
AND THEY
HUSTLE FOR THE BALL.
TRY NOT TO GIVE UP BIG PLAYS.
I
THINK THEY WILL BE SOLID AGAINST
CLEVELAND.
THEY HAVE DOMINATED
PEOPLE ON THE GROUND THIS YEAR.
I THINK IT'S GONNA BE A FUN GAME
TO WATCH.
>> YOU SUMMED IT UP.
THEY PLAY
HARD.
THEY HUSTLE TO THE BALL.
THEY GOT A BUNCH OF GUY GUYS.
AND I
HAVEN'T SEEN A DEFENSE GET FIVE,
SIX, SEVEN EIGHT GUYS TO THE
BALL LIKE THESE GUYS GET TO THE
BALL.
THEY PLAY WITH A LOT OF
PRIDE.
AND YOU LOOK AT KENNY
MOORE, XAVIER RHODES, WHO WAS A
CAST-OUT FROM THE VIKINGS.
HE'S
BACK UP THERE PLAYING WITH
CONFIDENCE, PHYSICAL.
AND I
ACTUALLY THINK WAS THE NFC
DEFENSIVE PLAYER OF THE YEAR --
PLAYER OF THE WEEK LAST WEEK.
SO
YEAH, THEY'RE PLAYING GOOD
DEFENSE RIGHT NOW.
>> YES.
GO AHEAD, COACH.
>> MIKE RODNEY WOULD APPRECIATE
THIS.
MATT EBERFLUS RANKS MOST.
IF YOU SLOW DOWN, OBVIOUSLY,
BEFORE THE WHISTLE BLEW THEN YOU
GET A LOW.
BUT THE FIRST TIME
ROD MAYOR NELLY GAVE WARREN SAPP
A LOAF.
BECAUSE HE SAID I RAN
ALL THE WAY ACROSS THE FIELD AND
MADE THE TACKLE.
NO, BUT YOU
WEREN'T RUNNING AS HARD AS YOU
CAN.
THOSE FIRST FIVE YARDS, YOU
WERE LOAFING.
THAT'S THE WAY
MATT EBERFLUS COACHES.
>> I LOVE IT.
>> AND JAMIE RHODES, IF HE
PLAYED IN MINNESOTA THE WAY HE
WAS PLAYING THIS YEAR, THEY
WOULDN'T HAVE CUT HIM.
HE'S BEEN
GREAT.
AND THAT TRADE FOR
DEFOREST BUCKNER.
THE COLTS KNEW
HOW SCREWY THIS WAS GONNA BE
WITHOUT THE FULL OPPORTUNITY TO
SCOUT PLAYERS.
BUCKNER IS PAYING
OFF.
AND THAT DEFENSE REALLY IS
STEPPING UP IN A YEAR WITH NO
DEFENSE.
THE COLTS ARE THIS
THROWBACK UNIT.
AND IT'LL BE
INTERESTING TO SEE IF THEY CAN
STOP THAT CLEVELAND RUNNING
GAME.
WHAT FASCINATES ME ABOUT
CLEVELAND.
307 RUSHING YARDS
LAST WEEK.
>> THAT WOULD BE THE GAME PLAN
FOR THE COLTS.
TO LOAD UP THE
BOX STOP, STOP THE GAME.
AND
BAKER, THEY DEFINITELY HAVE THE
BENEFIT OF A GREAT RUNNING
ATTACK.
THEIR DEEP END BACKS.
WIDE RECEIVERS.
BUT IF BAKER
MAYFIELD DROPS BACK KNOWING HE
CAN NO LONGER RUN THE FOOTBALL,
I THINK THAT'S THE COLTS'
OFFENSIVE GAME PLAN.
>> YOU TALKED ABOUT WHAT YOU SAW
WATCHING THE COLTS' DEFENSE THIS
MORNING.
IT JUST MADE ME THINK
OF WHAT I SAW WHEN I WENT BACK
AND WATCHED A LITTLE BIT OF THE
BROWNS/COWBOYS GAME.
I WANTED TO
WATCH CLEVELAND CLOSER.
AND THE
BECKHAM TOUCHDOWN, WHEN DALLAS
IS DOWN, 3.25 LEFT.
IF YOU GO
BACK AND WATCH THAT HIGHLIGHT,
WATCH THE DALLAS DEFENDERS.
THEY
GO TO THE SIDELINE.
TREVON DIGS
JUST STOPPED.
AND WE WERE
WATCHING HERE.
WE'RE SEEING MORE
JUST SIMPLE MISTAKES.
I NEVER
PLAYED, FLORIO NEVER PLAYED.
WE
CAN'T BE CRITICAL AT A CERTAIN
LEVEL OF WHAT GUYS ARE DOING.
BUT WHEN YOU SEE THAT KIND OF
STUFF, WHERE THERE'S A LACK OF
FINISHING A PLAY OR EFFORT, OR
SIMPLE STUFF.
THAT HELPS EXPLAIN
WHY WE'RE GETTING SO MANY POINTS
IN THE LEAGUE.
SOME OF THE
BASICS ARE BEING LEFT ON THE
SIDE OF THE ROAD.
>> THEY REALLY ARE.
I WAS
WATCHING THAT SAME GAME, MIKE.
AND ROD MAYOR NELLY WOULD BE
CRYING.
>> YES!
YES.
>> JUMPING OFFSIDE FOUR OR FIVE
TIMES IN THE COURSE OF THE GAME.
THAT IS NOT CALLED FOR ON HIS
DEFENSE.
AND SUCCESSLY, A GUY
RUNS 70 YARDS ACROSS THE FIELD
AND DOWN THE SIDELINE AND NO ONE
TOUCHES HIM?
NOBODY HUSTLES TO
CHASE HIM ALL THE WAY?
GUYS
STOP?
ABSOLUTELY WOULD NOT BE
TOLERATED.
>> AND COACH YOU SUMMED IT UP.
YOU SAID SUNDAY NIGHT,
FUNDAMENTAL FOOTBALL, YOU GIVE
YOURSELF A CHANCE.
IF YOU LINE
UP PROPERLY, YOU HAVE THE RIGHT
TECHNIQUE, AND TRY TO MAKE THE
TACKLE.
DALLAS, THEY'RE NOT EVEN
HUSTLING.
THEY'RE NOT PLAYING
PHYSICAL, THEY'RE GETTING
COMPLETELY DOMINATED.
TYRONE
CRAWFORD COMING BACK FROM
INJURY.
I THOUGHT HE WAS GONNA
REALLY BE A GOOD PLAYER FOR
THEM.
I THOUGHT GRIFFIN WAS
GONNA COME IN AND DOMINATE AND
BE A GOOD PLAYER FOR HIM.
THESE
GUYS ARE GETTING PUSHED AROUND.
THEY JUST CAN'T CONTROL THE LINE
OF SCRIMMAGE.
>> THEY'RE 1 AND 3 AND THAT IS
RIGHT UP THERE A HALF-GAME
BEHIND PHILLY IN THE DIVISION.
SO THERE'S PLENTY OF TIME TO GET
IT RIGHT WITH DALLAS.
GIANTS AND
DALLAS PLAY.
THAT'S THE 4.25
GAME.
MINNESOTA 1 AND 3, SEATTLE
4 AND 1. AS YOU HAVE WATCHED
RUZEL WILSON, WHAT IS IT ABOUT
THIS YEAR THAT ALL SEEMS TO BE
COMING TOGETHER RIGHT FROM THE
VERY START AND MAG FLYING WHAT
HE'S DOING ON THE FOOTBALL
FIELD?
>> I TALKED TO THEIR COACH, AND
EVERYBODY CAME TO AN AGREEMENT.
THEY HAD GONE TO THE SUPER BOWL.
THEY HAD BEEN GREAT FOR YEARS.
A
DOMINANT DEFENSE, RUN-THE-BALL
PHILOSOPHY.
AND RUSSELL WILSON
MAKING MAGICAL PLAYS TO PULL
GAMES OUT FOR THEM.
PETE CARROLL
AND EVERYONE SAID RUSSELL WILSON
IS OUR BEST PLAYER NOW.
WE NEED
TO FEATURE HIM.
WE NEED TO BUILD
THE OFFENSE, BUILD THE TEAM
AROUND HIM.
AND THAT'S WHAT
THEY'VE DONE.
AND I THINK
RUSSELL HAS FELT THAT
CONFIDENCE.
AND HE'S PLAYING
OUTSTANDING FOOTBALL.
>> YEAH, THAT'S A MINDSET,
COACH.
AND THAT MINDSET IS WE'RE
GONNA PUT THE BALL IN OUR BEST
PLAYERS' HANDS AND SCORE AS MANY
POINTS AS POSSIBLE.
YOU DON'T GO
OUT AND GET DJ METCALF.
YOU
DON'T HAVE THE SPEED OF TYLER
LOCKET AND DAVID MOORE, THE WIDE
RECEIVER.
AND NOT TRYING TO OPEN
UP THE OFFENSE.
AND RUSSELL,
HE'S DOING A WONDERFUL JOB.
THE
THING THAT STILL CONCERNS ME IS
THAT DEFENSE.
THAT DEFENSE IS
GIVING UP A BUNCH OF YARDS.
PEOPLE CAN MOVE THE BALL ON THAT
DEFENSE.
AND YOU CAN'T EXPECT
RUSS TOLL COME OUT AND SCORE
FOUR, FIVE TOUCHDOWNS AGAINST
THE BETTER TEAMS.
>> AND MINNESOTA WAS AWFUL THE
FIRST TWO WEEKS.
THEY'VE
REDISCOVERED DALVIN COOK THE
LAST TWO WEEKS.
GARY KUBIAK HAS
DONE A GOOD JOB OF FIXING THE
OFFENSE.
JUSTIN JEFFERSON HAS
COME ON STRONG.
AND MIKE
ZIMMER'S NEVER BEATEN THE
SEAHAWKS.
IT SEEMS LIKE EVERY
YEAR NOW, THEY END UP PLAYING IN
SEATTLE IN PRIME TIME.
THEY GET
TO GO OUT THERE WITH NO FANS.
AND THAT'S GONNA BE A DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCE FOR THE VIKINGS THAN
IT'S BEEN IN THE PAST.
SO YOU
KNOW WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN.
SUNDAY
NIGHT WE'RE ALL GONNA PICK THE
SEAHAWKS.
>> TRUTH BE TOLD, I WAS THIS
CLOSE TO MAKING THE FLIP TO THE
EAGLES WHEN I KNEW EVERYBODY WAS
GONNA PICK THE SEAHAWKS.
I WAS.
I JUST KNOW, EVEN IF YOU TAKE
THE LOSS, IT SAVES THE GREASE
FOR THE SPIRE TIME.
SOMETIMES
YOU HAVE TO TAKE A SACK AND JUST
PROTECT THE REST OF TEAM.
THAT
MAY HAVE BEEN THE MOMENT TO DO
THAT.
>> TYPICALLY THAT'S YOU.
>> I KNOW.
>> I'M GONNA GIVE YOU GUYS A
LITTLE HEADS-UP.
IF YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT MAKING YOUR PICK
FOR THIS WEEK.
BEEN THIS.
THINK
ABOUT WHICH TEAM IS GONNA BE
ABLE TO RUSH THE PASSER BETTER.
MINNESOTA PLAYED GREEN BAY EARLY
IN THE SEASON.
AARON RODGERS
DROPPED BACK 44 TIMES.
THEY
DIDN'T TOUCH HIM ONE TIME.
IF
THEY DON'T TOUCH RUSSELL WILSON,
IT'S GONNA BE UGLY.
FLIP IT
OVER.
KIRK COUSINS, HE'S GOT
SOME WEAPONRY.
AND JUSTIN
JEFFERSON, THEY'VE GOT GUYS WHO
CAN TORCH SEATTLE'S SECONDARY.
SO I'M THINKING ABOUT THIS, AND
I'LL BE THINKING ABOUT IT UNTIL
SUNDAY.
WHO IS GONNA BE ABLE TO
RUSH THE PASSER BETTER?
>> 63-59.